he was an American self-help author and
motivational speaker his first book the
erroneous zone is one of the
best-selling books of all time with over
35 million copies sold worldwide he
spent most of his early life up until
the age of 10 in an orphanage on the
east side of Detroit after his father
walked out on this family
he's Wayne Dyer and here his top ten
rules for success you can't give away
what you don't have now it sounds
ridiculous okay
but it's more than what meets the ear as
you hear this you can't give away what
you don't have people who are not good
at giving away love can't give away love
because they don't have it to give away
if I want to give you a dozen oranges I
can't give you those dozen oranges
unless I go out and pick up 12 oranges
someplace otherwise all it is is just
empty rhetoric and the same thing is
true of virtually everything in your
life you can't give away love for others
if you don't have love in here to give
away if what you have in here is
contempt if what you have in here is
anger if you haven't here is fear then
these are the things you're going to be
giving away in your life the second
thing that the ego teaches us is that
Who I am is not only what I have but Who
I am is what I do what I accomplish and
so we spend a big hunk of our lives
believing that the way that we become
quote successful happy fulfilled self
actualized whatever it might be is on
the basis of what I accomplished what my
resume looks like how many promotions I
get and so we send our children off to
school and we ask them to learn to
identify themselves on how much they get
and what they accomplished your grades
become more important than what it is
that you are studying
what you own what clothes you wear what
labels you have and so on and we become
obsessed with this kind of absurdity and
we this is the false self at work there
are many ways to get the things that we
want for ourselves in our lives but
basically it all begins with how we
choose to think as you think so shall
you be seven little words that I think
are perhaps the most important things
that we can learn and master in our
lives
this old proverb notion that I become
what I think about all day long and once
you know that what you think about is
what expands you start getting real
careful about what you think about you
don't allow your thoughts to be on
anything that you don't want or that you
wouldn't want to have manifest or show
up for you in your life have a mind that
is open to everything and attached to
nothing one of the central principles of
my life is that no one knows enough to
be a pessimist about anything and that
each and every one of us when we close
our mind to what is possible for us or
what is possible for Humanity closes off
the genius that resides and lives in
each and every one of us having an open
mind doesn't necessarily mean finding
fault with all of the things that you've
been taught by others it means opening
yourself up to the potentiality and the
possibility that anything and everything
is possible so having a mind that is
open to everything and attached to
nothing really means finding within
ourselves the ability to get rid of a
trait that I find so common in
contemporary in the contemporary world
do you know that most people that I meet
spend their lives
looking for occasions to be offended
they actually are out there hoping that
they can find some reason to be offended
and there's no shortage of reasons
they're out there everywhere the way
this person dressed what the worst
person said they turn on their TV they
hear the news they're offended by this
someone didn't someone use language that
they didn't like someone doesn't share
the same customs at you and people all
day long in fact if you keep track
tomorrow you will find probably a
hundred reasons that you can go around
being offended but a mind that is open
to everything and attached to nothing is
a mind that says I'm never looking for
anything to be offended by and that
whatever anybody else out there has to
say my response to that is that's an
interesting point of view I've never
considered that before when you change
the way you look at things the things
you look at change Albert Einstein once
observed that you have the most
fundamental and major decision that you
have to make in your life is this do I
live in a friendly or a hostile universe
which is it is it a universe that is
filled with hostility and anger and
people wanting to hate each other and
people wanting to kill each other
is that what you see because when you
see the world that way that's exactly
what you will create for yourself in
your life
this is from great scientific minds and
the interesting thing is that this is
not just a a clever play on words that
when you change the way you look at
things the things you look at change
it's actually a very scientific thing
and I'm going to show you that in just a
moment I'd like you to imagine the
following scene you're in your house
you've got your car keys in your hand
the lights go out
power failure you can't see a thing you
stumble around in your living room and
you drop your keys and you look around
for a moment and you realize that you're
never going to find them in the dark but
you look outside and you notice that the
street lights are on so in your mind a
light bulb goes off hmm I'm not gonna
sit around here in the dark and grope
around looking for my keys when there's
a light on outside I'm gonna go out here
under the streetlight I'm gonna look for
my keys
why are you laughing this is this makes
a lot of sense so you're out here and
you're groping around and you're looking
for your keys and you're looking and
looking and your neighbor comes along
and says what happened wait well I
dropped my keys
oh I'll help you look for and the two of
us are now down here looking for our
keys and looking finally he says to me
excuse me but where did you drop your
keys
well I dropped him in the house he said
you mean to tell me that you dropped
your keys in the house and you're
looking for them out here and the
streetlight doesn't make any sense and I
said well doesn't make any sense to
grope around in the dark when there's
light out here now you laugh and you
think how silly that is but isn't that
exactly what we do when we have a
problem a difficulty a struggle that is
located inside and we're looking for the
solution outside someplace outside of
ourselves it would be like going to the
doctor and telling him all of your
symptoms and the doctor says huh boy
you've got a lot of symptoms and he
starts writing out prescriptions you
need a prescription for this symptom you
need a prescription for that symptom and
finally he gets there's four or five and
you go to walk out and you say well I'd
like my prescriptions he said no no I'll
give this one to your mother-in-law and
I'll give this one to your neighbor and
then I'll give this one to your daughter
and I'll give this one to your father I
mean you're the one with the struggles
and with the difficulties and giving
expecting somebody else to change or
something outside of you to get better
in order for you to make your life work
at this level that I'm calling intention
is something you have to really take a
hard look at it's in here I used to say
that before I had children I had eight
theories about how to raise children and
now I have eight children and no
theories
but one of the things I know about
children is that no one likes being told
what to do and this isn't just children
this is all of us one of my favorite
songs it's a song from when I was back
in high school
I'll give Midland lots of land and the
starry skies above boy you know it don't
fence me in don't restrict me don't put
don't put boundaries on me don't tell me
what I can do and what I can't do don't
tell me how to be there don't tell me
what to wear what to think
don't tell me how to even how to do yoga
don't tell me I don't want to be told
this is the soul speaking always the
soul is constantly having a desire to
expand and grow and anything or anyone
that comes into your life that attempts
to do that you will find yourself
fighting it and reaching back there are
no justified resentments and this is a
very difficult principle for many people
to get but one that I believe very
strongly in I was in a group one time of
drug addicts and alcoholics and I was
one of the people that was a sponsor and
leading this group and the sign on the
wall said there are no justified
resentments in this group and what I
said to that group that that night was
no matter what anybody says to you here
no matter what kind of anger comes
directed towards you no matter how much
hate you may encounter showing up in
your life there are no justified
resentments meaning that if you carry
around
resentment inside of you about anything
or about anyone and I'm talking about
the person that you lent money to and
hasn't paid you back I'm talking about
the person in your life that you feel
was abusive in your life I'm talking
about the person who walked out on you
and left you for somebody else I'm
talking about all of the things that you
have justified in your heart and in your
life that you have the right to be
resentful about and I'm suggesting to
you that those resentments will always
end up harming you and creating in you a
sense of despair I've often said that
you know one ever dies from a snake bite
a snake bite will never kill you
you cannot be unbidden once you're
bitten you're bitten but it's the venom
that continues to pour through your
system after the bite that will end up
destroying you in my mind as I think
about this idea of getting what you
really want and being able to attract it
into your life what what what we have to
look at is basically the obstacles that
we have conditioned ourselves and you
notice I say that we have conditioned
ourselves because I have never believed
that we need to be putting the
responsibility on someone else if you're
conditioned it's because you have
allowed yourself to become that and if
we are conditioned if we conditioned
ourselves to believe certain kinds of
things and one of the things that we
kind of believe and hang on to and live
with is this whole idea that all of the
things that happen to me in my past are
what are keeping me from doing what I'd
like to do today so we hang on to these
things and we fill ourselves with blame
is they I'm the middle child I'm the
youngest child I'm the oldest child you
know I'm an only child any one of those
is a great excuse you know if you're the
youngest child you can say well you know
I never how could I be making decisions
for myself and
be a fully functioning person today when
I always had somebody else telling me
what to do my whole life how could I
think for myself if you're the oldest
child you can simply say to yourself
well how could I be expected to think
for myself I always had to think for
somebody else I was always doing it for
somebody else and that leaves the middle
child
you know the classic identity crisis so
for me
my mother didn't even know my name she's
always calling me by this one's name or
that one's name so I don't know where I
fit in
so that take care of everybody except
the only child and of course the only
child well your parents looked at you
and said we won't be doing that again
you have to live with that I don't I so
everybody with their birth order or with
their mother like their sister better or
that we had enough but we didn't have
enough or we had too much or we lived in
the north we lived in the south I'm too
tall I'm too short I've got too much
hair I don't have enough hair it's
falling out it's not falling out
whatever it is we all have these excuses
and I call all of these things that we
hang on to and use to keep ourselves
from reaching these higher places in our
lives the wake I call it the wake and
the wake is comes from a story that I
heard Alan Watts tell one time it was a
very powerful story he said your life is
like a boat and it's heading up the
river at say 40 knots and as it's going
you are somehow able to metaphorically
stand on the stern the back of the boat
and look down into the water now there
goes your life in this direction and
you're standing here and you're looking
down into the water and you ask yourself
these three questions the first question
what is the wake what is it what is this
thing that you see and the answer the
wake is the trail that is left behind
that's what it is nothing more nothing
less
it's the trail that is left behind
second question to ask yourself in this
little metaphor what's driving the boat
what's making this thing go in this
direction the answer
the present moment energy that's being
generated by the engine and nothing more
that's the only thing that's making the
boat go in this direction and in this
little scene this means it's the present
moment thoughts that I have and how I am
using them that is making my life go in
this direction and nothing more because
the third question is the most important
and powerful question and I've ever ever
since I heard it I've always thought
about this whenever I have a tendency to
look back here and blame something is it
possible for the wake to drive the boat
that is Hana trail that is left behind
make a boat go in this direction and of
course the answer to that is no it can't
it's just a trail that is left behind
and in that trail there are an enormous
number of things that every one of us
has awake and we have a whole lot of
stuff in it and one of the problems that
we have is that we have a tendency to
look at the wake and all of the stuff
that's in it to explain why it is my
life isn't working the way I would like
it to work so this was something that
Portia Nelson who I knew who passed away
a few years back 10 years back now she
lived up in Seattle and she had she was
at a seminar and they were asked to
write the autobiography of their life in
five five versus five chapters so and
they gave them only like cards this size
actually they were smaller than this
they were three by five cards so write
out chapter one of your life and just go
to where you are today and I remember
doing this very same thing but what she
wrote was so brilliant that I asked her
daughter if we could put it on public
television which I did on the most
recent show and we made a contribution
to Porsha's work so this is what she
wrote down in the chapter five of her
life chapter one
she said I walked down the street
there's a deep hole in the sidewalk I
fall in I'm lost I'm helpless it isn't
my fault and it takes forever to find a
way out chapter 2 of my life I walk down
the same street there's a deep hole in
the sidewalk I pretend I don't see it I
fall in again I can't believe I'm in the
same place it isn't my fault it still
takes a long time for me to get out
chapter three of my life I walk down the
same street there's a deep hole in the
sidewalk I see it there I still fall in
it's a habit but my eyes are open I know
where I am and it is my own fault and I
get out immediately
chapter four of my life I walked down
the same street there's a deep hole in
the sidewalk I walk around it Chapter
five of my life finally I walked down
another Street now great the next
principle I call don't die with your
music still in you and who better to
quote than Thoreau right here in Concord
when he talked about some of us here a
different drummer and we must march to
the music that we hear but all of you
everybody watching everybody here in
this beautiful parish all of you have
some music playing and all of you have a
heroic mission
there's no accidents in this universe we
all show up here with a purpose
there's an intelligence that is a part
of everything and everyone and all of us
are connected to it and too many of us
are afraid to listen to that music and
March to it
you out there I know you have a book you
wanted to ride I know there's a
composition you wanted to compose I know
there's a song you want to sing
someplace maybe you want to raise horses
out in Montana well maybe you want to
open up an ice cream shop on Cape Cod
who knows what it may be maybe you just
want to travel and see the world maybe
you want to go into a relationship with
someone but you've been afraid to but
your heart says it's the right thing to
do all of us feel something and in leo
tolstoy famous novel the death of Ivan
Illich he asks this question that would
be terrifying to me he says as he has
this accountant from Moscow lying on his
deathbed contemplating the horror of
this question what if my whole life has
been wrong I've known what my music is
it's playing right now as I stand here
in front of you with these cameras and
in this place and as I sit down and
write my books and tell the world what I
know are my truths I feel always
completely on purpose and fulfilled and
no time will I ever come to the end of
my life and say what if my whole life
has been wrong whoever you are whatever
that music is however distant it may
sound however strange however weird
others may interpret it to be don't get
to the end of your life and know that
you're going to leave and not have it
played yet don't die with your music
still in you thank you so much for
watching I made this video because Jason
Haines video man Jason Han asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
this leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of wayne's top 10 rules meant
the most to you leave it in the comments
I'm gonna join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon